made entirely of gold encrusted with
sapphires and diamonds this Faberge egg
is remarkable but so is the story behind
it there are perhaps no objects as
romantic as Imperial from G Easter eggs
created by Carl Faberge in 1887 for the
Russian royal family it was seized
during the revolution and sold by the
Soviets it vanished for half a century
that was until an American man bought it
at a junk auction in the Midwest for
$14,000 he wanted to melt it down but
instead contacted Faberge expert Karen
McCarthy a gentleman had it miss
unassuming modest person you could
imagine and he walked up to my desk
which is in this room and presenting of
a sheaf of photographs in which there
were pictures of this one of the
greatest pieces of gold work ever to be
created the egg has already been sold
reportedly for 30 million dollars
McCarthy wouldn't confirm that but he
says another inferior Faberge egg went
for 18 million to find one of them is
the luck of not just one lifetime at a
thousand lifetimes and he had found one
these are the things we hunt all day
every day and to be presented with one
was the most of spine-tingling ly
exciting moment the egg goes on display
in London from April 14th there are
another two missing from this very same
collection they're out there somewhere
waiting to be found
Angus Bennett Bloomberg